now you might think I'm going to tell
you what you're doing wrong I'm not I'm
going to tell you where we have gone
wrong like mistakes that we've made in
the past so that we can all learn from
them so that you can make different
mistakes and come here and tell us about
them I will say you know do this and
don't do that I'm not telling you what
to do I'm this is a short formulation
for these are the conclusions that I
have come to so that you can perhaps
come to different conclusions or speed
up the your path of learning and in
everything whether it's data engineering
whether it's playing the piano you know
if you don't know any rules or
guidelines it will sound terrible once
you get some things in place you can
provide value play as time goes by but
in order to like do something really
good you have to bend the rules so I'm
trying to convey the sort of rules and
practices that I have come to conclude
you might come to different conclusions
why am i standing here what am i
suitable to do this well I've had the
I've been very lucky in my career in a
couple of aspects I work for some very
good companies that are really good at
these things and picked a few things up
from from very talented people and the
last two and a half years I've been an
independent consultant and I've been
helping a whole bunch of companies so
I've seen more like big data
environments that most people and in
that many environments there are some
patterns emerging
things that people do over and over
again and that's what I'm trying to
convey to you so how do I find a mistake
well a mistake is something that
prevents you from reaching your end
goals and there are actually different
angles out there my definition of an
angle is like some kind of profit like
either money or happy users or something
of business value that there are other
goals out there whether consciously or
unconsciously and that's fine but that's
that's my definition for the sake of
this talk and we do notice that people
make a lot of mistakes this is a Gardner
quote that maybe 60% fail mistakes was
an underestimation I think it's like our
sorry
60%
Big Data projects was not an estimation
maybe it's like more like 85% and I've
seen some companies fail I've seen some
companies succeed I'm trying to convey
the what I see as a difference this is a
general blueprint this is the data tech
conference I assume most of you are
familiar with it you have services doing
things on one hand you they emit events
that you collect or they have store data
and databases and you collect that data
put it into some kind of cold store role
zone where you sort of keep it forever
if it wasn't for GTR and then from there
you bill like processing pipelines
Sparky loop whatever your favorite thing
is and at the end there's a Negro stage
where you take things out of your data
lake and push it to make this make it
useful man this is pictures focused on
batch there is a stream equivalent I
will come to that later in the talk so
as you start out and this is the way
that people started out years ago and
some Sun and but it still happens is
that you you write a little batch script
or something and you take the data that
you collected for a particular hour and
you run spark on it because spark is a
decent tool and then you want to do
something on a daily basis in this
example you want to count account some
before key performance indexes you want
to form sessions because if you want Pro
product insights into your into your web
shop or something so works fine for a
while then you add your campaign
management decides that you want some
more information so you add some job to
the write that is dependent on the stuff
to the left in order to can to calculate
the impact of your campaigns also works
fine for a little while but then
something goes wrong on the left and the
dependent job on the right breaks not
too bad you can you can go in you can
rerun it manually but you start to
realize that this doesn't scale beyond a
few yobs it's even worse with other
types of failures that might very well
lead to silent data corruption so much
later you will discover that you didn't
have all the data and you
doing the wrong calculations this goes
out of hand very quickly and the
solution to this is something that
manages your dependencies let's call the
workflow Orchestrator now there are a
bunch of them out there and if you only
remember one thing from this talk that
is pick up a good workflow Orchestrator
that is the one of the keys to success
unfortunately there are some some that
our week out there weak in the sense
that you cannot express all the things
that you need and you recognize them
because they are using a non expressive
languages as the DSL such as XML or
graphical interfaces unfortunately many
of the vendors ship the weak ones rather
than the good ones Google is the shiny
exception they recently four announced
the managed airflow service airflow is
one of the two good ones and the other
ones called Luigi both of these are
perfectly fine tools if you're not using
them have a look at them I tend to
recommend Luigi to my clients I'm a
little bit biased I used to work at
Spotify where we made Luigi but it's
much simpler it's it's easier to get
started with it has a smaller scope I
like simple tools they do one thing well
and that leads to simpler operations and
so forth but our flow has some some
advantages as well so it's a trade-off
all right off to number two
Hadoop can do a whole lot of things it
can look at the sequel database and it
can even do transactions these days so
that's great we don't need a sequel
database anymore we can ditch our own
ole Oracle database or what they want to
just use Hadoop and we have really
powerful tools that we can use queries
all over the data Lake to bring out the
data that we want in real time when we
need it by querying a lot of data sets
that sounds great now it's not so great
because that's not what these Big Data
technologies were meant for unlike the
relational databases they're distributed
disability technologies you sacrifice a
whole lot of things in order to gain
scalability and performance and
redundancy
now what you sacrifice is the
multi-purpose distributed technologies
are good at one thing typically one
thing only or maybe two or three but
with everything that you add you are
sacrificing you know you are sacrificing
quality so they had do technologies and
the old ceramic technologies were made
for offline processing not online
processing so if you're using them for
online just do as you used to do and
bring in newest technologies you're
actually making things worse and this
sort of big data revolution that we're
somewhere in the middle of is actually
not about new cool technologies or lots
of data yes there is some of that as
well but that's not where I see
companies getting most value will they
get the most value from new ways of
working and collaborating you instead of
these peer-to-peer organizations on the
Left where you have to talk to five
different teams in order to get your
data to do something innovative with
data you pour down you have an
organization that pours down all of the
data and democratizes it internally in
the organization which means that you
can do it data international faster
either in for botching the de lake or
in-stream storage for real-time
processing the other big benefit is
working in in pipelines where you save
the raw data rather than say processing
it first and then saying it so that you
can go back if things go wrong and you
can invent new things from the raw data
and this gives a tremendous iteration
speed and get really powers data
innovation if you get it right if you
are able to move quickly so say the data
in one company we decided that we wanted
to do important calculation it was
important that we got it right so all of
the nodes that were like saving data
collecting data we asked them to to sort
of push all the data into Hadoop and we
only started the calculations once all
the day
it was in their problem is that all the
data takes a while to figure out whether
all the data is in there and when those
started failing this took like longer
and longer longer and got more and more
fragile so the more we scale out the
worse the system rough and also this was
good for reporting well really needed
the good quality but if you just want to
do dashboards of products in site
quality is less important than getting
results quickly so there is no good
answer on how long you should wait
so another company said okay we're not
gonna wait we're gonna start processing
and then we're gonna monitor the lates
incoming data and when it once it
reaches 1 2 percent something we
recalculate downstream now this has
different disadvantages because the
downstream calculations are no longer
predictable and reproducible which is OK
for some cases but not great if you want
to do like machine learning or data
science experiments where you tweak your
algorithm and say did it get better no
the data change so you don't really know
on the tangential note on a different
company the people doing the event
collection said well we have this
service that you IPG you look ups
wouldn't the all the events be better if
we like decorating them away with some
geo information so let's do that before
we save the data that was fine we got
even better events until the our PTO
service broke down or did the wrong
thing and we're now had some events with
missing data or wrong data and that is
painful to recover from anecdote number
4 we had some processing where we needed
information in the database so Hadoop
spoke they can go and look up things in
databases to decorate the data so we
just go to the production database and
do that now if that if you're doing a
large computation that might take down
the production database but if you're
doing a small computation that's fine
until you need to rerun it because then
the production data has changed and your
pipeline is no longer producible
these four stories have in common they
are deviating from functional principles
now if you've learned functional
programming you might have picked up
principles of immutability once you've
written something never change it
idempotency right you should be able to
repeat operations and reproducibility
right everything should be deterministic
and whether we do in functional
programming or doesn't matter but this
is this these are the same principles
applied on an architecture level and
following the following these principles
makes your life a lot easier
so once you've written data sets let me
change them and make sure that your your
execution is repres
it's worth sacrificing it for good
reason but know when you are doing it
and why you're doing it so the the
solution to not go into in order to
avoid going to the databases from jobs
in production or production databases
from from Hadoop jobs you can dump the
databases on daily basis so for each day
like you have a copy of the database
that's great
there are tools like spark and scoop
that can go out to a database and dump
it so this is one of my favorite war
stories we had at Cassandra cluster
serving users was a big kiss under
cluster like 40 50 nodes something lots
of users and we wanted that information
on a daily basis and so we had a Hadoop
cluster and this lot of data so we had
like you know 20 then 50 then 100 Hadoop
machines going out to get all of that
data so that created quite a load spike
on the older son or trusted because son
is very scalable so it could sustain the
spike the spike became half an hour long
in an hour and two hours and one day the
spike got 25 hours long so we had a
double spike in in one hour
that took down the login service the
user people logging service people were
not happy so they put a network firewall
in between the Hydra cluster and cost
problem solved and we had to figure out
a better way so I wasn't paying
attention a couple years later somebody
wanted to do the same thing this also
with the login service and they decided
not to go to the database but go to the
nice little rest interface where you got
very clean data and of course the same
thing happened like this the the this
cluster brought down the login service
so this you can you can have her do
passes like a denial of service attack
you
this can happen on the egress side as
well this is a recommendation scenario
the people doing the recommendations
they had this great new algorithm so
they had computed big indexes for
recommendations and they wanted to push
this out to test it to the users so they
dumped it all in the Cassandra cluster
and Cassandra was replicated so cuz I
cuz I'm too happily replicated this to
the other data centers which took all of
the cross-atlantic bandwidth which was
needed to more much more important
things such as serving users so forth so
what we learn the offline is the offline
environment is very powerful it's a
internal denial of service attack
basically ready to kill your online
environments at any moment so you want
to separate these two environments right
in the online things are really
important if things break you have
unhappy users out there and they give
crappy feedback they shout on Twitter
and things like this so you really need
to like be proactive with making sure
that these systems are up the impact is
high so the proper built-in it's below
the offline world you have internal
people like like doing business insights
and so forth there are a few of them and
they are quite good at giving feedback
because they come to your desk so things
might go wrong right you you don't need
to protect these things as well in the
offline world so you can take a much
higher risk and do your sort of Quality
Assurance on a lazy basis when things
when things go wrong you go in there and
you do more quality assurance there much
higher return on investment on on those
type of quality assurance so what I
learned is to separate the online world
from the offline world the middle and
also from the online world at the end
and have very careful handovers in
between so for dumping databases for
example you can take a nightly backup of
your database bring up an offline
database and dump from that one that's
not serving any users anymore
and likewise if you're pushing like
recommendation machine learning models
out there throttle it and then keep
several versions of these recommendation
models or for detection models so you
can switch back to an old one if the
offline world fails you and you don't
need get new models on a daily basis you
still have a few old about so Ali is an
old colleague of mine and he decided to
do an academic career you know in the
middle of the big data hype in like 2007
8 or something he decided to go to
academia and I said I work at Google
time like Alec come and work with us
we're doing super fun things no no I'm
gonna go to academia and then they built
this thing called spark and then he
under by accident he ended up being CEO
of the coolest startup one of the
coolest startup ever and he says like we
have clients with petabytes and
petabytes of data and they all want to
do machine learning and I'm sure they
have those clients in fact there are
companies that generate petabytes of
data say they have like a billion users
or they have things like jet engines
that produce approximately as much data
as a billion users now most companies
don't have petabytes they have like
gigabytes because they have uses the
producing few kilobytes per day and they
are the number of users is limited by
the you know the number of swedish
speakers or something so you actually
don't need scale and your data might
very well fit in memory well if you go
for clusters anyway you you are taking a
very large cost because in distributed
systems lots and lots of things happen
that never happened on single machine
environment and you want to make sure
that if you go into cluster so scaling
out
but you get value for paying all for all
of these problems and costs so mistake
number five minutes like scaling for
imagine or engineering for imaginary
scaling problems your data is likely to
fit the memory on the largest cloud
instances or at least a portion of your
data remember the the value of big data
is not about about sizes and necessarily
machine learning either but about new
ways of working in collaboration and
enemy in the most successful project
I've been in we're using spark but never
in clusters we're only using it in local
mode this is say a this is a company who
has very little business outside of
Sweden so we know we can't get more than
10 million users or something everything
fits a memory only local mode works
great so a client went came to me and
said we have this issue that things are
going slow about the day are you sure
storing things in s3 is a good go
strategy here and they pointed me to two
blog posts and that made me figure out
what they were actually doing this blog
post they have a job that reads like one
year of data every day and there was
another situation where we were having
this large cluster and there was this
system that was using like a large
portion of the cluster all the time and
we figured out they must be doing
something really important it turns out
that they would be reading years and
years of full raw data on a daily basis
hundreds of terabytes computing
something and then dropping it all so
the next day they would read hundreds of
terabytes again so usually you don't
need to do that and it's better to
change your algorithms so that they are
incremental so you can process the new
data and do as much as you want or as
much as you can
typically aggregate on the daily basis
and then even if you want results on a
regular base results for more than
for a long logic time period you do only
the final part of the computation so in
this example let's say you want to make
a top list of the of the most popular
countries where your country where your
customers are or the countries that
plays the most orders and you want to do
that on a daily basis or the rolling one
year window if you do it the nay way you
would read all of the raw data I join
with you use a database and produce the
top list every day if you do it in an
incremental way you would each day count
the number of users in each country so
you join with use a database and you do
the heavy computation day by day and
then only in the end to do form the top
list
you need to do you take the aggregate
this is lots of data this is a small
amount of data
this is compressible okay splendid so
the data Lake has has like a real time
variant as well it's called the unified
log instead of putting it all those
things in batches of files in your lake
you put you put it in a stream so that
everybody can consume this is the data
take conference you're very familiar
with it you can do similar pipelines
like the stream processing that spits
out data to new streams and do the same
thing but but in real time is that a
batch and surely this must be much
better I mean you get you don't have to
wait to the next day to get results you
some things you think need to be quick
and in particularly the demos look much
better right and you've heard some some
cool companies say that these this is -
what the cool guys are doing now this
comes with the cost and this cost is
called operations if you change things
in your streaming environment you need
to be much more careful so if you change
your schema for example you need to do
it in a careful manner because if the
you're spinning are new data and your
downstream pipelines or downstream jobs
get gets confused by the new data they
will
and then you will have an operational
problem if you do the same thing in
batch they will crash as well but batch
is very forgiving because there are
things like the workflow Orchestrator
that will retry your failed jobs so once
you fix that you recover again there are
ways to deal with this this is scenario
is more difficult if you have a bug and
you spit out invalid data then your
events will spread out through all of
your pipelines and some of them will be
bad and is instead of having you know 10
batches of bad things you have like 10
million events that are bad so you have
to reach out to figure out which ones
are the bad and try to discover myself
this isn't much more difficult scenario
to recover from and there are no tools
to really help you here if you compare
this with batch and take the operational
scenario where you have a faulty job up
there and it produces some like faulty
recommendation in mixes or something
what you do is you realize oh no the
indexes are bad let's revert to the old
ones because you say that you're saving
a few copies of the old ones right now
you fix your bug and then you just
remove the faulty data sets which are I
could proximately ten of them you can
look in your workflow Orchestrator
because it keeps a dependency tree so
you know which they are you can build
tooling for this but it's it's people
haven't because it's fairly easy to do
and then you're done nothing more
operationally to do right because the
word proc is straight you will see
though some datasets are missing and
will refill for me at least if you use
Luigi with our flow it's a bit more
complicated but it's still not difficult
this means that you can recover from
programming errors in like about thirty
minutes even though they were in
production and this speed gives immense
power to your data innovation but you
only get this a batch this is a
confluence blog post on how to recover
from a similar scenario in with Kafka
streams it's a lot I don't know it's
it's actually a really good blog post
they describe very well
they do fantastic work but it all it
doesn't cover the pipe lesson I read
only it only works for if you have a
single job and not a food plan final
jobs so by all means go for stream
processing but make sure that you pay
price in terms of operations so make
sure that you have a use case for it
right or that you perhaps you have a
case where the data call it is not super
important so you're only feeding
dashboards or something that's fine
now the good news is that this gap is
decreasing because the tooling is
getting better confluent is doing a
fantastic job on pushing this to the
world and so I see some things coming
out of Google as well so hopefully you
know like five years or something I
can't be standing here and saying this
all right
some sometimes the data looks wrong you
discover that after a while I was in a
team where we really cared about the
data quality really cared about getting
things right and we're taking lots and
lots of data from from the rest of the
company and so the manager called us the
sewer of the company because everything
that people who were doing wrong or
hazely upstream like we had to deal with
at one point we saw that well wait a
minute this content type is supposed to
be like text or audio or video something
in one day was a content type [ __ ]
in some of the messages it turned out
somebody pushed or like an experiment to
production upstream and they never
notice that we of course noticed so
unless you are proactive with monitoring
quality like this you will find problems
weeks months years later and then they
are much more expensive to deal with and
there are four quality dimensions to
care about timeliness is producing
results on time that that one's not so
difficult because if you don't produce
things on time people explain
correctness is about doing getting in
the computations right testing can help
you here so that one's fairly straight
cord completeness is more difficult
that's but making sure that all of the
data you wanted to compute on all of the
things that happen during the month are
actually in this month's data
likewise consistency if you if you have
two data sets that are supposed to
contain the same things like to reports
pointing to the same thing do they
really have the same input data and the
latter two you need to monitor for there
are no tools or things out there that
can help you so the mistake is writing
your pipelines and then be happy you
need to monitor the contents and you
have a good one good tool is called
counters or aggregators or accumulators
so whenever you code and you see well
this item here it's supposed to match a
user in the database what if it doesn't
ask yourself right and if it doesn't
pump a counter
don't do anything smart just bump the
counter so that you can monitor whether
things match your expectations or not
that's how we found out about the
content i bullshitted
incident you need to go a bit further
than that I'm actually measure
consistency between the data sets and
between the records and the data sets
and so forth likewise here are no tools
to help you as well and the counters is
one reason that where I reckon it's one
reason that I'd recommend people to stay
off of sequel processing for for really
important pipelines because
sequel makes you forget about these
things there are no natural places to
put in these counters or compensate for
that all right
things break and sometimes you do
something wrong sometimes somebody else
has done something and then inform you
so so things break the effect here is
that you become locked until you become
careful oh I'm not sure I won't change
this because it might break something
downstream and we had a situation where
we were the old pipeline was no good so
we built a new pipeline and that was
really quick it's you can move things
you can innovate quickly unfortunately
changing and removing old things takes a
lot of time so we had the old one
running for like 18 months or so and
that that old one was a lot of burden to
us
so the problem is that these changes
that you want to make are often in
different teams so your your it's
difficult to go across the team
boundaries so what do you have what you
end up with is an inability to move
quickly we measured this in one company
we concluded that if we if we collect a
new field at the client the average time
for this to be used at the end was like
one month and this is this is a good
company like very agile independent
teams and so forth right I've also seen
teams where we don't have the
communication channels and there's no
there's no upper limit to how long time
it takes to propagate new data from
upstream I've also seen environments
where this is technically tightly
coordinated and then you can move on the
order of days this significantly impacts
you're able to to innovators are
different at the high speed the remedy
the only remedy I am aware of is to do
testing unturned so that you have a safe
testing environment so you know when you
break things then you can move fast but
this is often against the company
culture if you have autonomous teams the
this can be difficult to do all right
you've heard about the functional
principles like you do imitability and
you in order to be reproducible you dump
all of the user data basis everywhere so
you have thousands of copies of the user
database and so forth and this is all
great until somebody knocks on your
shoulder and says what about privacy
what about erasing users okay wait a
minute
and the most expensive engineering
mistake that I've seen was most made in
this area it turns out that takes a lot
of effort to wash petabytes of data so
you don't want to be in a situation
where you haven't plan for this likewise
if you allow your teams to do like to
choose arbitrarily anything of
autonomous teams and they are supposed
to be able to deploy really quickly
without connect coordinating which will
not
people you end up in a situation where
you have variance in things that don't
really matter such as time format I
think I counted to somewhere around 25
different formats in one Larry Daley
Lake
some of them were really crazy but we
couldn't change that because we were
like in the internal testing and also I
had this situation where the I was
riding a pipeline and I was trying to
use beam and I was happily writing along
when the job was done turned out that
the input data was actually per K and I
never looked because it was like ever
everywhere I said yeah yes I could have
looked but this is something this
needless variance is something that adds
friction to your innovation speed so
what you need to do there are some
things that you need that you are better
off planning early and I'm sorry through
throwing like an enterprise buzzword at
you here my definition of governance is
the things that you should have done
proactively so that would have prevented
you from from a painful situation later
and you can put anything in the heavy
one and there are a couple of types of
painful situations that you can be in
the ones to the right or like risk
situations you found that you are not
compliant or you have insufficient
security or whatever so that's that's a
way of risk mitigation once to the left
are all about your innovation speed your
ability to innovate with data quickly
we've been through the development speed
it quite a bit I want to point out this
one I've seen a whole bunch of teams
that say oh data is valuable that's
great I have a lot of data
it's my data and they didn't want to
share that they don't want to put it in
lake or in the stream now it turns out
that a bit of governance can loosen that
up so if you say well you're not not
actually putting it in the lake and then
everybody can do anything on it there
are rules here in the lake
and one of these rules can be they need
to go and talk to you before they use
your data right so that you limit the
degrees of freedom in order to make
people want to share a few comfort
chattering right so rules and degrees of
freedom can in it can increase your
speed so if you look back there a couple
of themes here one is up in the right
corner is to sort of gravitate towards
complexity more than protecting business
value and working towards business value
the other one is to sort of gravitate
towards interesting technology or new
technology more than the sort of the
principles of Big Data and principles of
pipeline and data sharing data
democratize democracy and so forth and I
find myself saying to clients over and
over again a whole number of things if I
keep things simple scope down as much as
you can focus on the value what's the
value of this pipeline that we're
building or this technology we're
building and you can have hyper profit
for each actually you think that you
cannot both the these the efforts that
you have if you go for the hype things I
mean to go for the profit things are
completely different you might notice
that none of the things that I say have
anything to do with technology so here
are some links the upper three ones are
similar talks but less technical more
about building teams and organizations
and so forth if you found some of the
things that I said here confusing or you
wanted more know about the context I
suggest you go for the reading list and
the last one is some of my old
presentations from from other
conferences questions yeah thank you
very much
anybody has a question so I have one
question what do you think from your
experience what are the 10 mistakes
falls the most biggest problem in your
experience
well I think that the picking up the new
patterns the the pipelines and the
collaboration is where you have the most
profit if you come from a like a legacy
environment so and I think that's one of
the reasons where I see where we see so
many enterprise projects fail right
they're just bringing in new technology
and then they're just making things
worse likewise this one is the workflow
Orchestrator is yes it's new technology
but it's super simple and it really
saves your sanity right and it makes you
think in terms of pipelines and in terms
of the delivering value the internal
agility
that's mistake everybody makes right i
I've seen I only see few companies
actually be good at this and they are
very coordinated every they have a very
specific company culture so so you can
you can thrive without the tree a
mistake is more costly that depends on
your environment right if you're in an
enterprise environment this one is bound
to be costly because you will set out to
do it big project we I've seen a bunch
of like data like projects and then go
on for years without and then then they
start producing value once they've sort
of picked important things up so you can
spend a lot of money there but if you're
a start-up that's not where you start
right so it depends on your context
Steve great toklas purely hypothetically
imagine you've got multiple data sources
one of them is using one of those random
time sources and they're an hour out so
your data's coming out wrong how would
you go about debugging that sorry I
don't understand how would you go about
debugging say one of your data sources
is slightly dirty so your answers are
coming in they're out how do you you
know begin to go backwards from bad
results to from bad results - too bad
incoming data yeah
yeah I've done that on a number of
occasions in substant emore we care
about the results there are no shortcuts
so once you end up with the bad results
you just have to debug step by step but
from there you can improve right so so
this was in it in a company where we had
a strong tradition of learning from
mistakes and doing post mortems and so
forth and in those I mean these kinds of
issues were always post mortems because
they we cared about that that particular
those particular datasets so we would do
you know five whys and see what went
wrong why did it go wrong how can we
prevent this from going wrong in the
future and we would include all of the
teams affected all the way out to the to
the data collection and the client right
and see so you must improve here in
order for us to get the get the reports
right and then this also was in the
company where we had a very transparent
culture so the results of the
post-mortems were shown to everybody in
order to have the kind of culture you
must have a culture of no fear so you
must be allow yourself to be vulnerable
and nobody must ever never ever get
punished for doing something wrong and
being open about it
unfortunately changing culture takes a
long time any more questions yeah Laos
thank you very much for coming here
thank a reputation
[Applause]